Now in the human genome, there's a consensus sequence that's
usually about 30 to 40 base pairs away, in front of
the transcription start site of most genes. So here we
have the transcription start site indicated by the arrow and the
plus one. The coding region is over here to the
right. And in front of it over here, we have the
promoter region. And in the same way that we would start
counting plus one, plus two, plus three, down our coding region.
And that would start measuring counting right the number of
letters that are going to be in our mRNA transcript. We can
start counting backwards to get the numbered positions for our
promoter region. So we have minus one, and minus two and
minus three. And we can go on back to the
minus 30 to the minus 40 region. So let's focus in
on this region about 30 or 40 letters or base
pairs upstream or in front of this transcription initiation site. Here,
I'm showing you six different samples. Not different genes,
not different promoters. The same promoter from six different
people, let's say. So we have six different people
and this is their sequence. The, the letters in
their promoter region at this minus 30 to minus
40 region in front of a specific gene in
their genome. What I want you to tell me
now that you've learned about what a consensus sequence is,
is look at these six different sequences and
tell me what is the consensus sequence for these
six positions in the minus 30 to minus
40 region of the promoter for this hypothetical gene.